I think it's a really basic point of
curiosity in the world and people that
come to MIT are very passionate and want
to change the world should know how
airplanes fly some information about
aviation and the incredible feats of
humankind to be able to fly through the
air today on the podcast we're talking
flight specifically how a course has
been designed and refined to allow
hundreds of students to pursue a path
toward flying I thought that it was very
important that anything that's
interested in this have the opportunity
to learn about airplanes and learn how
to become a pilot themselves
welcome to choc Radio a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT
I'm your host Sarah Hansen from MIT
OpenCourseWare in this episode we'll be
talking about MIT s flight school with
two of its instructors philip greenspan
and tina shrivastava in our conversation
they share how a number of innovations
have made the course incredibly popular
both in and outside of the MIT community
part of why we want to highlight this
class is that its evolution has allowed
for a nimbleness of structure without
sacrificing the effectiveness of its
instruction it's truly fascinating that
something as seemingly technical as
flight school can take so many different
shapes
I wanted to dig into how it's possible
to find flexibility and instruction with
such high risks and also what made this
course so successful at attracting and
preparing future pilots we'll pick up
our conversation with Philip and Tina
explaining what it means to have access
to flight school and what it really
takes to take flight people have been
wanting to fly for thousands of years
and only in the last hundred years has
it become a practical reality and the
u.s. is unique in that it's you know
half our third the price here and much
easier to do in the US than any other
country so as long as people are here in
the US for whatever reason you know
they're never going to be probably more
than half an hour's drive or an hour's
drive from flight school they're going
to you know have the ability just as
ordinary consumer with a credit card to
spend five or ten hours mastering the
basics of flying so you know one thing
that I've tried to stress in the class
is that you know they don't have to
commit to getting an FAA pilot
certificate which means that you're safe
to be the only pilot in the aircraft you
can go down the flight school you can
get your hands on the controls and
within five or ten hours learn to take
off fly around land without the
instructor having to touch anything or
say anything and that's doable for both
airplanes and helicopters just
motivating people to you know try to get
up in the air and enjoy this unusual
freedom that we have here in the US I
jumped in as part of the staff a year
ago and I spent about a month going
through the powerpoints to emphasize
that this is an activity that can be
done safely especially with a two pilot
crew you know maybe it's the instructor
and the student or maybe it's a
certificated pilot and another friend
who happens also to be a pilot so I I
did that and then some of it was just
wording people naturally who are pilots
unfortunately they'll tend to stress the
hazards and how they avoided them I
think part of it as it makes them seem
more impressive so there were a lot of
powerpoints that says well you know they
have they had the form of you will die
if you will do X so I just added them to
say you'll be safe if you're not X but
it was it was still hard we had a guest
lecturers an aerobatic instructor it
okay you know he spent some time talking
about you know the hazards of mid-air
collisions and how people avoid them but
you know if you look at the data that's
only 2% of accidents it's not a common
way to have an accident at all so you
know why do I scare people about it
obviously it's good to avoid any
accident but he didn't he didn't share
with the students like I'm telling you
about something that accounts for only
2% of accidents right
they're sitting there terrified I would
be flying on and all of a sudden
somebody lo smashing them the course
format has evolved from a weekly
two-hour course taking place or an
entire semester and turned into an
intensive three-day program this change
has created more interest in the program
and allowed more and more students to
not only pass the FAA exam which is the
courses intended goal but to go on and
actually earn their private pilot's
certificate so I got engaged in the
course 1667 the private pilot ground
school in 2015 at the time I was
completing my doctorate at MIT and as we
continued to teach the course over time
we discussed the potential of changing
the structure of the course and last
year was the first time we changed the
structure of the course the stead of
being to our lectures in the evenings
over the full spring semester it became
a three-day intensive course in the new
learning format I think the advantages
are that the students can focus
exclusively on this course for three
days so they're not distracted with
other courses or other activities
they're just focused and living and
breathing everything about becoming a
pilot that's necessary and I think that
level of engagement has a different set
of advantages and the last year was the
pilot of the new format and it was very
successful in many ways we had about 101
students on the first day and we
completed the course with about 98
students that was a big accomplishment
and we engaged a lot of the students to
get in terms of not only completing and
passing the FAA exam but continuing that
enthusiasm and getting their private
pilot certificate in my conversation
with Phillip and Tina it became clear
that there was something important about
having this class meet in person it
seems like exactly the kind of
content that might easily be converted
to an online format but there was
something that made an in-person
gathering not just useful but essential
here so I asked them why not just do
this online so MIT students are really
good at reading books and this material
to pass the test you can self-study
successfully you know people do that at
commercial flight schools they must go
home they read all the FAA books which
are available online in PDF so yes you
have to ask yourself you know what is
the what's the purpose of even having
lecture halls and a university when
there's so much available online and
when you have a population of people who
are great readers and reading this three
times faster than listening in terms of
you know just being able to get through
information so that was part of why we
said well look we can do this in three
days because we're not going to try to
cover everything and spoon-feed it to
people they can read the book so I asked
them to do a little bit of pre reading
and then we'll inspire them we hope with
the in-person experience and then they
can go back to the books whereas they
think the traditional class you know
assumes that people don't have access to
a lot of information outside of the
course sure if they or they have to be
decided with a row spoon-feed you with
the problem set or a reading assignment
yes absolutely
I would even say that less than half of
the course was about the FPAA knowledge
exam and the reason I would say that is
that I think that so much more of the
course was about becoming a pilot a lot
of the discussion and the interaction
and the interactive discussions were
really focused on decision making which
is very critical for a pilot just
because you can answer a factual
question about the weather for example
doesn't necessary
you're fully evaluated whether it is
safe to fly whether there are alternate
options available how you go through
that full decision-making process we
discussed everything from aircraft
ownership shared rentals flying with
friends going on vacations to really try
to share with students how they could be
empowered as a pilot and we provided a
lot of tips and insight from our own
flying experience for example in the
case of night flying the idea of trying
to take off before the Sun has set is
that you begin to acclimate to the night
environment over time these types of
insights and experiences are not part of
the FAA knowledge exam but were some of
the most important pieces of the course
based on the student feedback you
received so it's really about what the
students are interested in and engaged
in throughout the three-day class we
also have a number of breaks and at
every single break we would have
students come up and either share an
experience or ask a question or for
clarification and that type of feedback
also helped us inform how we talk to
class and how we connected different
elements of the course together to help
answer or provide some enlightenment on
a particular topic and how it relates to
other topics one of the things I was
most curious about was how Tina and
Phillip were able to bring over 100
students working at different paces
through this material these classes are
often so full that there's a whole other
overflow classroom to accommodate the
numbers what does it take to do that
one of the ways that we engage them is
you know a traditional method of just
asking a lot of questions and we would
call up students to answer them
we had a very engaged group group of
folks sometimes we'd ask questions where
we asked students to raise their hand to
give us an answer and sometimes we ask
students to shout out an answer okay a
couple of times we used some FAA
practice exam questions and we would
have students kind of raise their hands
whether they thought it was you know a B
or C and depending on how divided dudes
were on the answer we knew whether we
needed to spend more time on the topic
or not so for example one of the
questions that we asked them was a real
question from the FAA exam and a
question that I got on my own FAA exam
which was about right-of-way when you're
flying okay so it was if you're flying
and there is an aircraft refueling
another aircraft a glider and a blimp
which has the right-of-way and this was
a really good question
generated a lot of differences of
opinion we had basically a split
students guessing all three options so
I'll I'll leave that interesting
question there without the answer so
you'll have to view the course to find
out yeah I guess what I would add is
that you know it was good to have we had
fairly frequent coffee breaks and meets
a break but a lot of it was you know the
the slide presentation to the students
was really there to set the stage and
you know just having Tina there or the
PhD and aero-astro that's way above the
beyond you know what people would have
available at a typical flight school
really look at the engineering
trade-offs instead of you're saying this
is how it works this is your here's your
cessna you know it converged on this
design sometime between the 30s and 40s
you know one good thing about aviation
is there's a huge amount of government
to produce stuff
has done a you know a good to great job
about making graphics available for
every kind of aviation topic so we mined
a lot of this public domain material
from from the FAA while having these
materials accessible in the public
domain can be a real boon to anyone
teaching complex materials it's rarely
enough just to point to the resources
and expect the knowledge to sink in I
wanted to know how these elaborate and
math intensive concepts were conveyed to
students in a way that empowered them
not only to pass the FAA knowledge test
but to be informed practicing pilots to
conclude our conversation I asked Tina
and Phillip how they go about creating
clear and useful instruction on complex
topics and they told me about a critical
lesson in the class weight and balance
we're weight and balance what you're
talking about is you know how you load
the aircraft in terms of the fuel the
passengers the baggage and how that
affects the flight and so we used a
physical model airplane to really
demonstrate the effect on an airplane if
your center of gravity was too far asked
on the airplane we also solicited input
from the classroom regarding their
weight and weight the bags we give them
insights and tips that whenever they're
flying to not necessarily trust what
their passengers tell them is the weight
of their own weight so to be safety
conscious maybe apply effects or safety
on what your friends tell you that they
weigh and we used a book to show how you
can do calculations and we also went
live on online to the website of certain
flight schools to show how you can find
the exact gross weight and loading
characteristics of different aircraft
and different online calculators that
calculate weight balance for you and
project that and then finally we also
showed how to do those calculations on
an iPad with form flight so we showed
again different ways to approach the
same information and materials so that
it wasn't just a an academic description
of how to calculate weight balance but
truly how they would do that as a pilot
not just the FAA regulations for it but
how they would go about doing that for a
flight that they say fly
if you're interested in learning more
about becoming a pilot or just about the
flight school itself you can find the
flight school materials on our website
at ocw.mit.edu and if you're an educator
check out our special portal on the site
just real at ocw.mit.edu slash educator
thank you so much for listening and if
you like what you've heard so far please
consider subscribing and leaving us a
review until next time I'm Sarah Hansen
from OCW